so zubots spent a lot of time here at
the free throw line here in the first
quarter we still have two and a half to
go
of course the clippers missing kawhi
leonard fifth consecutive game with that
sprained right knee they're two and two
without him injured in game four in utah
and with his family
here in a sweep at staples center
they've got
very little information about leonard's
injury just that it's a spring right
neither were some reports that there was
a tear he wouldn't be back for the
season flippers said no
it's on a day-to-day basis the update
will not play
spring right knee and he's here cheering
on his
teammates tonight ayton gets it inside
flips it up and in deandre
terence man
third team foul
[Music]
patrick beverly clicking on all
cylinders leaving the ball game getting
acknowledged right now but
offensively scoring defensively
disrupting
the crowd showing true appreciation
[Applause]
beverly started the first two games of
the playoffs
and was sent to the bench was out of the
rotation even some games had some
did not play coach's decisions but came
back in the starting lineup
in game two of these conference finals
and his defense a huge part
of the job they've done on devin booker
the last two games
and certainly instrumental especially
without the former defensive player of
the year kawhi leonard
he has led them defensively